JESS SCHWARTZ: Welcome.
Thanks to everyone for coming.
My name is Jess Schwartz, and
I'm a community manager for
Google Search.
I'm thrilled to be introducing
Zach Ware of the Downtown
Project in Las Vegas.
In addition to being one of our
talks at Google, this is
also one of our Google community
talks in which we
bring in outside leaders to talk
about online and offline,
in this case, communities.
When I learned about the
Downtown Project almost a year
ago, I thought about bringing
them to Google for a variety
of reasons.
And I assume we have a variety
of people in the room that
represent these.
At Google, we embrace
big ideas.
Trying to make a Las
Vegas into the most
community-centric city on the
planet certainly is one.
No matter what office you work
in at Google, whether you're
here in Boulder, or in
Beijing, the type of
relationship that Las Vegas
wants to have, our rather
that's Zappos wants to have
with Las Vegas is very
different than the kind
of relationship that
we imagine at Google.
It's also intriguing to consider
that many of us here
at Google are fans of Zappos
and its culture.
You only need to look at our
mail pods to see that.
And finally, plenty of us have
visited Las Vegas, but how
many of us have really
considered what it would mean
to not leave and to call
us Vegas home?
When I initially reached out to
the Downtown Project, Zach
and Tony agreed on one
condition, very smartly, that
in exchange for having one of
them come, we send someone to
their speaker series.
So a big thanks to Meng, our
Jolly Good Fellow here, for
making this possible because
he went to Las
Vegas on our behalf.
And now we have Zach.
ZACH WARE: I think Las Vegas
got the better end of that
stick actually.
JESS SCHWARTZ: And also a big
thank you to my partner in
crime for the talk series,
Jacky Hayward.
And the biggest thanks of all
goes to Zach for being here.
He focuses on creating the most
connected city in the
world in Downtown Las Vegas as
a part of Zappos and Tony
Hsieh's Downtown Project.
He's the founder and CEO of
Project 100, and co-founder of
Work in Progress.
He focuses on connectivity,
mobility, and infrastructure
in the Downtown Project and
is a general partner
at Vegas Tech Fund.
And along the way, he developed
and launched Zappos'
downtown Las Vegas campus after
heading up tech product
management Zappos.
So let's give a warm
welcome to Zach.
[APPLAUSE]
ZACH WARE: Thank you.
So that was--
is this working, can
you hear me?
Oh, this is probably for people
elsewhere, right?
So that's one way of saying that
I came from tech, which
I'm sure a lot of you are
focused on, and the last 2 and
1/2 years, been helping to
develop a city, including a
300,000 square foot building and
a variety of other things.
So I think it's kind of an
interesting story about how we
can take the concepts of
product management, the
concepts of technology
development, and
apply them to cities.
And it's frustrating
at the same time.
I'm going to tell you
a few stories.
I'm going to tell you a little
bit-- it's really weird to be
giving a talk and not
hear the microphone.
That's very odd.
So I'm going to give you have
a few stories about how we
about how we've approached
Las Vegas and why.
I'll tell you the history of why
we came to be in downtown
Vegas, and how that's
evolved over time.
To give you a little bit of
background about me, I
actually grew up on
a tobacco farm.
And I learned to drive on that,
which is a little, it's
actually pixelated, but it looks
just about as bad when
it's in HD.
I'm a computer science
guy, an econ guy.
My career started in food, and
it stayed in food for quite a
while, and then moved into
product management at Zappos
through some very odd
serendipitous interactions.
That was me in 2010.
And since 2010, I've had the
opportunity to do things sort
of in reverse order.
My work in downtown Vegas, and
Tony's work in downtown Vegas,
really centered around
the new headquarters.
And I'll talk a little
bit about how that
evolved over time.
We launched Vegas Tech Fund.
We started Downtown Project
after really realizing that
the opportunity and the need in
downtown Vegas was larger
than just what our company could
do inside of our campus.
Work in Progress was something
we thought we started to focus
on helping startups find space
and tools to be successful.
And then some of you might have
heard a little bit about
the largest order ever placed
for Teslas in North America.
That's Project 100.
We placed an order for 100 model
S's, and I'll tell you a
little about that, and how it
impacts how we think a city
can function.
I have to do this just for
the sake of my assistant.
It's the cutest thing
you'll ever see.
I just found out about two weeks
ago she sort of quietly,
without telling me, has been
managing a pretty large Etsy
store where she makes knitted
things for babies.
And it's the cutest thing
you've ever seen.
It's a mermaid with a
little bikini top.
That child is going to hate her
parents when she's older.
So a little bit of background
on how we started our
evolution in downtown Vegas.
You all know about that Zappos
and our culture.
And really, the number one
thing for us is, as the
company's evolved, and
particularly as we get to
scale today is keeping
that culture alive.
The number one reason we're able
to provide the customer
service we provide, the
happiness to our customers,
and, ultimately, the happiness
of downtown Vegas is because
our focus almost exclusively
on culture.
And so one of the ways that
sort of came to pass was
through our core values.
One of the things Tony will
tell you is the number one
regret he has in building Zappos
and starting 15 years
ago is what we didn't create
the core value sooner.
And they really aren't this
thing that we created at the
top of the company
and passed down.
It's something that really
came from the bottom up.
And these core values are what
we hire and fire against.
And as we evolved over time at
Zappos, we really started to
think more about how those
applied at scale.
And that's important to remember
as we evolve through
the talk today.
So we have this thing at Zappos
we call the three C's--
clothing, customer, service,
and culture.
And those are three things
we focus the most on.
Clothing really came out of this
idea that we wanted to
grow out of being
a shoe company.
And even today, if you go on
Zappos, 90% of you will see on
the home page will probably
not be shoes.
We're housewares, bags,
and much, much more.
That recipe, those three C's,
and that focus on culture, as
you guys know, propelled us not
only to over $1 billion in
gross merchandise sales,
but, this year,
we'll be over $3 billion.
A couple of years ago, we were,
obviously, acquired by
Amazon.com.
But through the processes, it
remained very independent.
And a big part of that is
because of our core values and
our focus on culture.
Currently, we live on
this really kind
of nondescript campus.
I was talking this morning about
how the multi-building
campus structure can be
really challenging.
And for us at Zappos, we've
grown out of this-- number
one, this was our
building two.
Building one was really for
about 150 people, and then
300, and then we took the next
floor, and then the second
building, the next floor, and
the third building, which
became like Siberia where people
go to work, and you
don't see them for four months,
and you wonder, when
you see them, how long, maybe
they've been on vacation.
You're surprised they
still work there.
And so what we've been able to
do at Zappos with our culture
has been in spite of the
building that we're in.
So through the course of the
last about seven or eight
years, really kind of starting
when we went to the second
floor of the Henderson campus,
it was really important to
think about how we could get
everybody under one roof.
We aren't growing as fast, from
a headcount standpoint,
as you guys are.
So we can think about maybe
one gigantic building.
And that might last
us 15 years.
For you, that would probably
last you about 15 days.
But at Zappos, we could really
think about a corporate campus
that's maybe three times of
what we have today as
something we can think of
as a 30 year investment.
So we started looking
at campuses.
We looked at Nike.
We came here.
We were inspired by what Apple's
doing in Cupertino, by
the spaceship-like object.
It looks like it's just going
to take off one day.
And the reason we really liked
is probably one of the main
reasons you like this campus.
It's the prevalence of all these
services, these things
that not only keep you here from
7:00 AM to midnight, but
really do make your life a
little bit better-- the bar,
the sushi place, the park,
the things to do.
And that really goes
to the heart of a
lifestyle of a company.
And as we thought about it, we
thought, yeah, we want the
Yoga studio.
And in the Nike campus,
they have a pub.
And around the edge, they
have a running track.
And we thought, yeah that's
actually what we want, too--
the pub part.
We really don't care about
the running track part.
And the more we thought about
it, though, we thought, this
feels like the same thing
everyone else is doing.
But for some reason, every time
we go to somewhere like
New York, we're really inspired
by the overlap
between a student at NYU, and a
person working in a company,
and the people that interact and
run into each other from
different backgrounds.
We like this concept of a busy
storefront and a busy street,
people interacting in ways
that they didn't plan,
co-working spaces, the concept
of being able to just camp out
and not necessarily be inside of
your campus, and ultimately
this is the photo that we looked
at, which kind of looks
like one of micro
machines photos.
But it really sort of gets to
the heart of how we see a
vision for how a
city operates.
It's these collisions and this
density that creates these
opportunities for amazing
things to happen.
And the reason that mattered was
we were thinking about the
growth of the company, and
when you get to a certain
point, we were currently in
about 1,500 employees.
When you get to a certain point,
you begin to lose that
happiness, and that innovation,
and that
productivity.
A lot of middle managers
come in.
People get siloed.
They are in three different
buildings.
Lots of things happen that
ultimately drive down the
reason why we get up and go to
work in the first place, which
is to be happy.
And so we found, when we looked
at research on cities,
which happened to be a very--
it was very just sort of random
thing a few of us were
reading about, we realized that
the exact opposite is
true for cities.
As a city doubles in size,
productivity and happiness
increases by 15%.
But it's not all true
for companies.
So our thought was, what would
happen if we took the lessons
of Zappos and applied them to
the work we think of a city
could use it to invest in
culture in the spirit of
optimism and happiness but also
take the lessons of the
city and apply them
to a company.
And a few different bodies of
research, Jane Jacobs, Ed
Glaeser, which I'll talk about
in a minute, and many, many
others, we found there were
three key elements to creating
this environment of serendipity
that really makes
a city magical.
That's residential density of at
least 100 people per acre,
street level activity, the
kind of things you see
happening here is kind of a
version of the street level
activity, and a culture of
openness and collaboration.
When you look at, historically,
back to Rome all
the way through the successful
cities of the last 1,000
years, the things that the
cities that made it through
the hard times were cities that
had those elements 100%
of the time.
Cities that didn't, like
Detroit, took an element like
number two and said, no, we'll
build an elevated train and
put all the activity
above the ground.
And ultimately, that small
decision, which was designed
for convenience to connect
different people from
different parts of the city,
ultimately drove down the
culture of innovation.
It was a good idea, but it was
a key contributor to the
failure of the core
of Detroit.
So we thought, how can we take
all these things, wrap them up
into one, one recipe,
and invest in our
company going forward.
And we recognize that a key
part of Zappos culture was
maximizing serendipitous
interactions--
having one door in
and one door out.
We liked the concept of density
in the office--
partially because we were cheap,
and we were all kind of
crammed on top of each other,
but more and more the research
that we realized that the
density in an office, the
typical 200 square feet per
person, was actually something
that was causing a lot of
rifts between people.
So we felt that we could take
some of the density ideas that
could make a city successful,
apply them to our company, and
ultimately make decisions that
allowed people to connect more
freely and prioritize collisions
over convenience.
And I'll show you an example
about that in a minute.
So the thing about downtown
Las Vegas, it was going to
sort of serendipitous
that a bunch of us
were hanging out there.
We were in a sort of
nameless city.
Vegas is a place, we were just
talking about it over lunch--
Vegas is a place that no one
feels like belongs to them.
You live in someone
else's city.
If you've ever visited Vegas
as a tourist, you
kind of take over.
And when you live in Vegas,
you feel that power coming
from the strip.
We found this little enclave
in downtown Las Vegas, this
two block area that had a really
amazing coffee shop, a
lot of really cool things
happening with a very small
group of people from the arts
area, from the creative area,
from the music space.
And we said this is actually a
place we want to hang out.
So a few of us were
independently hanging out there.
And as we were thinking about
the evolution of the campus,
we discovered this building,
which is, it's not like you
can't see it from a mile away.
But we discovered the building
that would soon become the
former Las Vegas City Hall
was becoming available.
And we thought that was
interesting because, one, it
was about twice as large our
current office, which made a
lot of sense for us.
And two, it included about five
acres of property, which
would allow us to expand
over time.
So this idea of creating an
urban center for our company
was something that was actually
within our reach,
instead of going out to the
desert and building a really
great but, ultimately,
lonely campus.
Bars like Downtown Cocktail
Room, which I highly suggest
you visit if you come to Vegas,
or the Beat, which is
the center of activity in
downtown Vegas, upstairs and
behind it, is emergency arts,
which provides 100 to two
square feet for artists to have
small galleries for $200
to $300 a month, which is the
first time in Vegas that
independent artist have the
opportunity to display and
share their craft--
versus a massive gallery at
the Bellagio which an
independent artist would
never get into.
So we started thinking a lot
about the way that Apple
campus looked, but started
taking the same things that we
saw there and saying, well,
how do we bring those to a
city and ultimately flip
our campus inside out?
Take what we'd normally put in
the courtyard, and put it on
the street, and make it
open to everybody.
What would happen
if we did that?
And on the way, we came up with
this idea that maybe we
should start thinking a bit more
about the community as a
part of what we're doing
in our company.
So we added a fourth C to our
three C's and are really now
super focused on community.
And that word is used a
lot to describe a lot
of different things.
Obviously we're talking
to the community team.
A lot of you are--
so for you, the definition
is one thing.
For us, it's a little
bit different.
But it all centers around this
activity of connecting people.
So we thought, yeah, that little
map I showed you second
ago looks kind of good.
But it would look a lot better
if it looked like this.
And as we thought about it more,
we thought, this little
piece of property that we have
on the north side of downtown
Las Vegas probably isn't
the best place
to center the activity.
We're telling everybody we're
moving our company to an urban
core, but there is
no urban core.
There's a coffee
shop and a bar.
And occasionally, there's
a festival.
But that's it.
So we started Downtown
Project.
And this is an independent
effort outside of Zappos that
most people think is
a part of Zappos.
Headlines will read, from the
writers that don't necessarily
do the time to do the
research, that
Zappos bought a motel.
Zappos did this.
Zappos did that.
When in fact, anything
that isn't our
campus is Downtown Project.
And what Downtown Project is,
it's something that people
think has been around for
four or five years
because of all the--
it seems like we have our things
together, and all of
our plans in a row, but,
trust me, we don't.
We came up with this
idea in late 2011,
launched in early 2012.
And the last 18 months have
really done a lot to help
invest in revitalizing
the city.
But every day--
we like to refer to it as
a city is a startup--
every day is a little
bit different.
So Downtown Project is an
initiative of about $350
million of primarily Tony's
personal funds and a few other
investors that's focused
on four key areas.
And I'm going to talk through
the why of those in the next
few minutes.
$50 million to small business.
You remember when I talked
earlier about the
ground level activity?
Our thought processes is,
instead of investing in
creating the activity
artificially, and bringing in
a McDonald's, or a Subway, or a
Starbucks, we want to invest
in independent entrepreneurs
who are passionate
about what they do.
The concept that we're trying
to follow is that instead of
having one gigantic idea that
brings activity to the ground,
let's invest in 1,000
small ideas.
Those 1,000 small ideas are
going to be more exciting.
They are going to be more fun
for you guys to hang out with.
And three, they're more likely
to collectively be successful
because they create a density
of creativity and excitement
that a Starbucks or
a Subway can't do.
We're investing $50 million
in the startup community.
Most of that is through
Vegas tech fund.
Some of it is through a
few other initiatives.
$50 million in education arts
and culture, which is an area
that is actually quite a bit
of fun and a little bit
surprising.
And then $200 million
in real estate.
And on the real estate front,
we're going to talk a little
bit about the concept of
curation and why we're
acquiring and redeveloping as
much as we are, but in as
little a disruptive
way as possible.
So you won't see in any of the
areas that we're focusing on,
an edifice of a shrine
to Tony.
When I was talking about real
estate, the ultimate goal for
downtown project is to create
an environment where people
can live, work, and play within
walking distance.
We talk about creating the most
community-focused large
city in the world.
And the way we've actually
evolved over the last year is
to really think about that as
the most connected large city
in the world.
Community focus is a weird
thing to interpret, but
connected is an easy thing
to understand.
And one of the ways we do that,
and one of our biggest
focuses is to really invest in
creating what we call the
co-learning and co-working
capital of the world.
This doesn't mean we have tons
and tons of co-working spaces.
It means that everything we do
is about creating places for
people to gather, to work,
to connect, to teach.
Every one of you has a skill
you can teach everyone
else in this room.
And the trick in the a growing
community is to pull out the
formalities and allow you the
opportunity to share those
skills with someone who
wants to learn them.
So in a lot of ways, we're just
creating an environment
the supports that
kind of thing.
In fact, One of our biggest
investments is in Skillshare.
And I'm having drinks with
their CEO tonight.
And for the last year, we have
been their number one test
city for creating opportunities
for people to
teach, and share, and learn,
which has been a really
interesting thing to see.
I took a basket weaving class
about eight months ago, which
was one of the weirdest
things I've ever done.
So at our core, when we think
about return, people ask us
how does this work
as a business?
And that's a fun question
for us to answer.
There's a couple of technical
ways that I
sometimes approach it.
But the easiest way to
understand it in terms of how
we're spending $350 million
and what we plan
to get out of it--
it's not a charity.
We're not handing this money
out to anyone who wants it.
We don't consider it to
be money that is gone.
It's very much a for-profit
endeavor but in a way that
people maybe don't understand.
We focus on what we call ROC.
We like to look at all the
investments that we make and
think about how they
collectively create community.
So if I invest in a residential
project, or a
restaurant, or a co-working
space, or a music festival,
what are the elements of that
idea that help create
opportunities for people
to connect.
And then, collectively, when
you take all those
investments, maybe 1, 2, 10, 50
of them don't have a clear
business model up front.
But they solve a chicken
and egg problem.
A startup won't come to town if
they have a ton of family
people, like kids in their
family that don't have
anywhere to play, that don't
have a dog park.
So what business model
does dog park have?
It enables 30 or 40 startup
employees to come live in a
neighborhood.
So we look at everything we
do as a way to invest in a
collective, versus a
single, investment.
And the other way we look
at that this concept of
serendipity, which is something
that just came up
not too long ago after we read
a couple books that focus on
this, we started thinking
about this concept
to return on luck.
And that's a way that--
for a long time, we had a
difficult time explaining why
we thought accelerating
serendipity made sense.
But what we actually realized
is if you look back at what
separates great companies from
decent companies, the one key
indicator of a company's
potential growth over time is
how they capture, and how they
sieze, moments of luck these
things that happen, these
interactions that happen,
these good things, these bad
things, and how to tackle
those things.
So to us, institutionalizing
these opportunities to connect
and take advantage of
opportunities that you didn't
anticipate having in life,
whether good or bad, is
something that can have a
massive impact on the way a
community evolves.
So our big bet, accelerating
collisions, commuting, and
co-learning will lead,
essentially, to happiness,
luckiness, innovation,
and productivity.
And that goes back to the
elements of a city that we've
seen successful over the last
thousand years but haven't
necessarily been employed, in a
deliberate way, really ever.
Because in every single case,
instead of breaking down
investments this way, developers
in cities break
down investments in massive
ways-- a big stadium, a big
research university, a massive
hospital, a billion project
that can pass or fail without
really anybody in the
community interacting with it.
Is it a good sports team?
Does anyone care
about the team?
That really isn't
in your control.
But if there are 1,000 small,
really amazing ideas, each one
of you can contribute to making
those successful.
And collectively, the
neighborhood can grow.
So I wanted to breakdown for a
second really quickly kind of
how we approach small
business.
People have asked us before,
they come to us all the time
and say, there's six or seven
of these amazing bars in the
US, don't you want
one in Vegas?
And we say, it'd be great
if there's one in Vegas.
We're just not going
to invest in it.
Because we want to have
something that is
story-worthy, that is unique,
that creates a sense of place
and an emotional connection
with the
community that's there.
And in a lot of cases, we find
our best investments from
people like Natalie, who would
kill me if she knew that photo
was up here right now.
And she's tough chef.
She'd been at the Hard Rock for
four or five years, and
hated her job, and was leaving
Vegas, and spent a lot of time
downtown, was working part time
at the coffee shop, and
everybody wanted to see her
stay, everybody wanted to see
her be successful, and four or
five different people started
coming up to us at Downtown
Project and saying, you've got
to find a way to invest
in Natalie.
At the time, we'd not told
anybody we were investing in
any restaurants.
We didn't have that idea we
didn't know any real estate.
But about six months later,
when we finally realize we
were going to have the
opportunity to do it, she's
the first person we called.
And she opened a restaurant
called Eat, which is probably
the busiest restaurant in
downtown Vegas right now, the
seven or eight that have opened
the last couple years.
She told us a number the other
day, that in the last year, a
little over a year, she's had
more than 100,000 meals served
at her restaurant.
That's 100,000 opportunities for
collisions that wouldn't
have been there before.
And it got to thinking a lot
about how we think about
investments as opportunities
to maximize collisions per
square foot, versus dollars
per square foot.
And I'll get to that
in a minute.
To our ethos of how we redevelop
real estate, we
bought a check cashing location
in the middle of a
Freemont East.
This is what it looked like
when we took it over.
In the back there, you see
the bulletproof glass
and the iron wall.
We met someone named Sarah, who
Tony's known for a while,
and a few of us just met a
couple of years ago, who has
always wanted to open
a fashion store.
So she took Checks Cashed,
and she did it.
She painted the floor, she
rusted up the back, and she
you brought in independent
clothing.
For the first time in Vegas,
you can go into a store and
buy the things you buy on Hay
Street, or wherever you might
shop in San Francisco.
You can actually
get independent
clothes in Las Vegas.
It's unique.
It's the first time it's
ever been done.
And every time you go in
there, it's different.
We liked the concept of
shipping containers.
I used to live in Hayes Valley,
and I was obsessed
with the proxy project, which
turned out, after I got to
know the people that built it,
it turned out to be quite a
more complicated for them to
build, and quite a bit more
expensive than they initially
anticipated.
But we had hope, and we wanted
to build it in Las Vegas.
And we started with four to
give this opportunity for
people to have a shipping
container with a restaurant,
or a bar, or a store, that
can rapidly test an idea.
Instead of spending half a
million dollar to build a
crazy beautiful storefront,
how do we basically
do what Proxy did.
We learned the same thing that
the Proxy folks did.
It's really hard, particularly
in a city that's never had a
shipping container as a building
before and cares a
lot about fire code.
We had some challenges.
But it gave us a chance
to experiment.
So we started building it.
We bought a Motel 6 which
needed to be condemned.
It's a half city block, and we
kind of went crazy and over
designed it.
Kind of photo bombing there on
the bottom right is Ern, which
is another story.
I just noticed that
earlier today.
I'm like it, really looks like
Ern is photobombing.
Ern is my neighbor.
He used to be a Zappos
employee until
about four years ago.
He left to build a barbecue
sauce business, and makes some
of the best barbecue sauce I've
ever had, and then got
into doing barbecue as
a catering operation.
Ern's one of the nicest
guys you'll ever meet.
That container right there is
actually the one that will
house Ern's barbecue in the
Container Park, which is this
massive center of activity.
It is the biggest real estate
project we've invested in and
probably the only one that we're
going to be building
from scratch.
It centers around a kids area.
So in the middle, we have this
element of a kids' play area
that's surrounded
by restaurants,
bars, and retail shops.
It's two stories on one side,
three stories on the other.
And when it opens, we'll have
30 or 40 small format retail
locations for small businesses
to experiment, again, without
having to spend half a million
dollars just to build a
storefront.
AUDIENCE: Where is that?
It's Freemont and 6th, or 7th.
Just an amazing center of
activity centered around the
kids area and a music stage.
If you guys aren't familiar with
Kaboom, those little blue
blocks are some of the
most fun things
you'll ever play with.
I've lost a lot of
hours to that.
And then moving into the startup
ecosystem, for us, the
environment of rapidly
creating--
this is something that I don't
need to spend a lot of time
telling you guys about, but
rapidly creating companies,
rapidly creating ideas in a fail
safe environment where,
with the right density, you can
create an idea, fail, and
you know ecosystem is
going to support you
getting another job.
This is what makes San
Francisco so magical.
That is the success of SF is
that I can go to work for a
crazy company, we can fail, and
I know that I'll have a
job the next day somewhere.
In Vegas, that wasn't
always the case.
So our focus for the first year
and a half was investing
in density of engineering
and startup talent.
We did that, and now we're
moving into the world where we
we're starting to see that
ecosystem pay off.
Our original idea was, taking a
look at the startup hubs of
the world, we said, what makes
that gigantic blue blob, or
the one in New York, or even
the ones in Austin, and
Portland, and Seattle
so powerful?
And what we found was the common
elements between all
the different startup ecosystems
were four things.
You don't mind if I cuss--
proximity to others working
on cool shit.
Proximity to those who
can help you access
to capital and space.
Basically, proximity, money, and
a place to do something.
And at the end of the day, if
you think about that formula,
it's really not that difficult
to create.
It's just a matter of someone
coming and doing that without
the normal gatekeepers that
you see in a lot of
communities, the application
process, the at the front door
who won't let you in.
Why can't a neighborhood
actually reflect what, to some
degree 500, or YC has done
with an application.
Proximity to others working on
cool stuff, people who can
help you, access to capital, and
Nevada's no where in the
top 25 of capital friendly
places right now, and space.
This is a map of all the
co-working spaces in the
country as of about
eight months ago.
First of all, Las Vegas had
zero, which was really kind of
depressing.
So we fixed that.
An our overall methodology
is pretty simple.
And this is something that
I share with the Zappos
technology leadership after
I left and was a part of
investing in four companies that
ended up pulling about 10
Zappos engineers out of
tech, so the VP of
engineering hated me.
And I explained to him that you
think about this concept
of three companies with
three people.
And one of these days, those
three companies are going to
be three companies that
have 10 people.
And somewhere along the way, one
person from each of those
companies is going to split off
and start his own company.
And that company is going
to be 10 people.
And right around there, there's
at least one, two,
three big companies--
in our case Zappos.
And what's so magical about
having that big companies is
there's someone there who wants
to start a startup.
And there's someone in a startup
who really wants to
have health insurance.
And when you create the
opportunity for those to
flip-flop back and forth, you
create this ecosystem where
you've got one guy coming in
from the startup into the big
company and vice versa, and it
just starts to revolve and
support itself.
Someone has to take
the hit up front.
And Zappos tech took
We lost about 20 people in
Zappos tech to different
startups over the last
year and a half.
But for us, it made
a lot of sense.
Google would not be here if it
weren't for the fact that
there's an ecosystem.
There's people that you
can draw talent from.
And that's what makes Silicon
Valley and SF work.
And we're well on our
way in Las Vegas.
Another area we focus is really
trying to create the
right pool of talent
and pool support.
So we made a big bet on
Venture for American.
We've actually just welcomed
our 14th fellow over
the last two years.
This is an organization, if
you're not familiar with it,
you should be.
Essentially, the founder, his
mission in life is to save
college graduates from
investment banks.
And so he takes these amazing
college grads from some the
best schools in the country.
And it's amazing.
It's only two years old.
But the people that you meet
number one in their class at
Georgetown.
And people who graduate
with a 4.9 from MIT.
These are people that can go
anywhere in life, and they
choose to follow
a startup path.
We invest in Teach
for America.
We have a major partnership
with them in Vegas to help
bring more teachers to the
downtown school system, which
is amongst the worst in Las
Vegas, which amongst the worst
in the country.
It's been a pretty awesome
partnership, and over the last
two years, we've been able to
bring up about 20 to 25 new
teachers to downtown schools.
We've invested in and are
opening this fall the 9th
Bridge School in a former
church building
that the city owned.
They're actually moving
furniture in tomorrow, which
is pretty impressive.
They're starting as a pre-K to
kindergarten and then adding a
grade every year.
And it kind of goes to the
heart of how we invest.
There's so much wrong with
education in the world, but no
one willing to take the bets.
So by investing in and creating
a fully private
institution that doesn't take
government money, we're able
to bring people like Sal Khan
and others in who have
innovative ways of teaching
people and try it in schools.
We get forward thinking parents
and forward thinking
kids to think about ways to
do education differently.
And it's all just a matter of,
for us, the big question is
why hasn't it been
done before.
And the answer to us is that
no one really just ever had
the guts to do it.
So we'll do it.
We'll give it a shot.
And if we fail, we fail.
And we'll do it publicly.
Education, arts, and culture.
Some of you might know
the Big Rig Jig.
It right actually in Oakland
right now being cleaned up to
be relocated permanently
to downtown Vegas.
It'll sit in the middle of
an old motel which we're
renovating into small-format
retail.
And it will be a centerpiece
that allows people to connect
and hang around, and ultimately
draws you in from
two to three blocks away, gives
you a reason to walk.
This is a picture from the
first Urban Burn at first
Friday, which is a festival that
we bought right before it
went out of business that
happens every first Friday.
And it was the first time that,
essentially, a Burning
Man, in this case, a woman has
been burned in the middle of a
city like this.
25,000 people came to see it,
pretty much all locals.
The Praying Mantis just
found its home at
the Container Park.
It happened to stop by La Comida
the other day and shoot
fire at it.
And it will be sitting
about two blocks away
from the Big Rig Jib.
So as you sort of get sucked
into that, you look over and
you see fire shooting
across the street.
And it's really just about
creating an environment of
surprise, and pulling you in,
and helping to create
something that you didn't expect
in your neighborhood.
So you can tell we're
not really about
big beautiful buildings.
We're more about really cool
experiences and something that
sort of surprising you and
keeps you guessing.
To our spirit co-learning, we
started downtown speaker
series, which, right now,
is what we were
just talking about.
I'm the b-squad that
they sent.
We've been hosting amazing
speakers about once or twice a
week for about a year now.
Two weeks ago, we had David
Copperfield doing a Q&A with
Kevin Rose and something
disappeared in the middle of
it, as totally to be expected.
We've had singularity.
We've had the CEO
of Whole Foods.
We've had Kevin.
We've had people that
you didn't expect.
Next week, we have Simon
Sinek, who is one of my
favorite speakers of all.
We have amazing people
coming through Vegas.
We have amazing things
happening.
And as we proceed over the next
couple of months, we're
actually creating a number of
venues that will support not
only one once or twice a week,
but once or twice a day.
And that creates an environment
where you know,
when you just want to take a
break, you can always see a
great speaker.
You don't have to
go to Ted.com.
On the culture side, this is
something that sort of
surprisingly happened.
We met someone who worked at
the Cosmopolitan who was
instrumental in creating an
independent music scene, or
burgeoning one in Vegas.
He wanted to do something more,
so we invested in Life
is Beautiful, which will be
pretty much the only time a 16
block area has been shut down
for a music and food festival.
It's going to be amazing, and
probably three months after
the Zappos campus moves in is
when it's going to start to
kind of take its hold on
downtown Vegas, which will
make it even more chaotic
once we move in.
And I wanted to show a quick
video just to give you a sense
of the scale.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ZACH WARE: So what's so powerful
to me about that is,
a year and a half ago, we
hadn't thought of it.
No one had thought of it.
And what's even more powerful is
that I recognize about half
of the people that are
in that video.
And it wasn't something that
we hired extras for.
It was produced by a company
that we invested in called
Downtown Films.
The video itself, I know
the guys that were
in the mouse suits.
I was standing on the sidewalk
saying I'm not going to dance.
And so the whole idea is
everything that we do.
So frequently comes
down to the people
that are in our community.
And we drive it forward
because we want to.
And that, to me, is
very powerful.
So back to what I said
about real estate.
If you haven't read this book,
you need to read this book--
"Triumph of the City"
by Ed Glaeser.
He's a Harvard economics
professor who did the
research, going back 1,000
years, to the way that cities
have evolved.
And a number of things that he
identified were, number one,
the residential density equation
that started to with
Jane Jacobs.
But he found that correlation
to ground level activity.
And we begin to think about it
a little bit more deeply--
that there's actually more to be
done than just creating the
residential.
There's a culture that you
need to invest in.
And so our focus through Life is
Beautiful, to the things we
create on the ground, it's about
creating and setting the
tone for that culture.
The residential will follow.
But I highly suggest
you read this book.
It is the reason why we started
Downtown Project.
We hadn't thought of in
the fall of 2011 until
we read that book.
So when I said that the cities
double in size, innovation,
happiness increase by 15%, the
ingredients of serendipity,
and all the things that I've
covered before, the concept
that we're thinking about now
is, what happens when we take
2,000 people, and we put them
in the Las Vegas City Hall,
and then we add the fact that
we have 1,000 Teach for
America core members and alumni
in Vegas and centering
themselves around Vegas?
We have this amazing startup
community, the small business
community of passionate
entrepreneurs.
Art and music, I mean, what
you just with Life Is
Beautiful is a collaboration of
hundreds of different types
of artists.
And then another different
passion communities, like
woodworking, or 3D printing and
robotics, which is a big
focus for us right now-- plus
everyone that lives there now.
You begin to get this mixture
of amazingness that you,
otherwise, wouldn't
get if you try to
pre-program It yourself.
So overall, we're basically
thinking that learning from
Zappos, we believed that culture
of being the most
important thing to a company
is sort of analogous to
community to a city.
And community is just another
representation of the word
culture and this feeling
of optimism.
And essentially that mixture
creates this amazing cut
opportunity for upward mobility,
this concept that
you can move somewhere,
be somewhere, and do
whatever you want--
embracing the concept of
serendipity over pre-planning
and pre-thinking
things through.
We experiment with ways
to connect people.
So once we have those people
there, what do we do?
We use things like the
Praying Mantis to be
a way finding tool.
In most cities, it's a sign.
In our case, it's a giant
bug that shoots fire.
We play around with guerrilla--
this was actually
a project in Raleigh that got
ripped down by the city.
But it was so popular with
people that the city came
along and ended up paying
the guy to do it
across the whole town.
And this guy's name is Matt.
And he has just amazing
ideas about how to
move people in cities.
And we say, why not?
We ask questions like
what moves people?
And most of you who've been,
obviously, in San Francisco,
you know where this came from.
The guys, Architecture for
Humanity, and this guy Matt
were the people that made
this happen in SF.
And we think that there's a
lot to be learned from the
concept of nontraditional
things moving people.
We asked questions like, what
does a streetscape do?
This is a map of San Francisco
that overlays crime, cabs, and
taxis and finds that where
there's more--
the yellow is actually a
representation of crime, and
the blue is a representation
of trees.
What correlation of do those two
things have on each other?
Clearly, it's pretty powerful.
Maybe it's not the single one,
but it's pretty powerful.
We look at cities like New York
and others and say, how
can we better invest in places
for people to gather on the
street and have safe
places to bike?
How are they going
to get around?
And then we make big decisions
like building a building for
2,000 people but only having
1,000 parking spaces.
And we say, well, now we're
actually probably going to
test this concept of mobility,
and walkability, and how
people are going
to get around.
So we asked the question, what
happens when you eliminate
cost as a factor?
And this is where I get
to my favorite topic.
What happens when you eliminate
cost as a factor and
essentially say, mobility is
free with the exception of the
monthly membership.
But that action of moving is
something that you shouldn't
have to think about.
What would happen if every one
of you had a car, a driver,
sitting right outside this door,
and they would be with
you within five minutes, and
you could go anywhere you
wanted to go, and it wouldn't
cost you anything.
How would that change the way
you move in a city when you
can't necessarily walk?
What happens when you bring
together every possible
mobility option and eliminate
you having to choose between a
taxi, an Uber, and a
bike, and a bus.
What happens to your sense of
mobility when you combine that
with a truly walkable city with
nontraditional way finding.
So we launch project 100.
We're in the process of
launching the company now.
And by the end of the
month, we'll have
12 full time employees.
But the end of next year,
we'll taken delivery
of 100 model S's.
Vehicles like Twizy,
where you--
Twizy's from [INAUDIBLE]
Renault we're bringing
into the urban core.
Federating bikes is a free
option for our members and
using shuttle buses to handle
high density routes.
We're reshaping point to point
transportation in a way that
cities can't do with a
subsidized $2 route.
But ultimately, on a per ride
basis, you're probably going
to pay a lot less than $2.
But the idea is, if you
eliminate the mobility
question from people's
lives, what happens?
How do they move around a 15 to
20 block area differently?
Can you go to four places in
a night instead of one?
Can you eat lunch across the way
and run into other people
that aren't necessarily right
across from your office?
How does that change how you
interact with people?
If you guys come to Vegas, and
you email me, I'll tell you
you should probably stay at the
Ogden, which is where Tony
and I moved a couple
of years ago.
I recently moved down
the street.
But he lives in the top
left corner there.
And we have about now
100 beds we treat
like free hotel rooms.
And the idea first was someone
would email us and say, hey,
I'm coming to town, what's
going on in Vegas?
And we'd say hey,
come stay here.
We have a bed you can hang out
and just work downtown for a
couple of days, which is our
way of tricking them into
coming, and hanging out,
and seeing what we
were working on.
And what we actually found from
those experiences was
kind of the same thing you learn
at an event like Summit
or Ted, where the magic of a
community is not what happens
when it's pre-programmed, but
what happens in between.
And that, to us, is actually
what Vegas can be every day.
So I'll speak more to
that in a second.
But we're investing in things
like the inspired theater to
support the speaker series on,
not only a daily basis, but an
hourly, or half hour basis,
where you always know you can
walk right on it at any point in
the day, and there'll be an
interesting talk by someone
who has something to share
every half hour, on the hour,
most days of the week.
They always silhouette
Tony in there, and
it's kind of creepy.
And so what actually ended up
happening was we accidentally
created this cadence
of things.
So first, it was about trying
to consolidate all these
amazing people in tech to come
on one week so they ran into
each other.
And then once they did that,
we realized there was a lot
more magic that was happening
than we could
ever possibly create.
So we start theming
every week.
Week one is First Friday
of the Arts Festival.
Week two is Tech
Cocktail Week.
Week three is a focus on
fashion, with talks and
workshops for fashion
folks, which you can
tell I'm not one of.
And Week four is kind of
everything else, Catalyst is
about inspiring a different
way of thinking.
It's sort of like a mini-Ted.
And so we did that.
And we realized, well, people
asked, well, what are you
doing to bring people here
over the long term?
And that got us thinking, well,
what does it actually
mean to be a resident
of a city?
And this is a simple
mathematical calculation.
If you take in travel, and life,
and different things you
have to do, you, generally
speaking, for most of the
year, in one year, you're
essentially collisionable, out
connecting with community about
1,000 hours a year, if
you take out laundry, and
errands, and so forth.
So this question came from a
guy named Jake, who, at the
time, had the biggest
fashion-related Kickstarter
campaign ever based
on underwear.
And this is another terrible
photo that he would hate that
we're showing.
But the question from him was, I
want to be a part of this on
a regular basis.
But I can't be here 100%.
I have a family.
I have a warehouse
in New York.
Is there a middle ground?
And so we thought for a second,
what does it mean to
actually be a purposeful person
in a community versus a
dedicated person?
So we did a little map
calculation and found that,
essentially, if you come for
three or four days a week, 12
times a year, your collisionable
hour is when
you're more purposeful, you
don't have errands to run.
You don't have kids to pick up,
you're actually about as
collisionable as I am by coming
once a month versus
being there all the time.
So we have this idea of
subscribing to downtown Vegas.
So what we have now is there's
a routine set of 20 or 30
people that we all see every
month for about a week.
And those people, in my opinion,
are almost more
collisionable and powerful in
the neighborhood than even I
am because I have things going
on, and they don't.
They're there 100%.
So back to our RRC calculation,
if you break down
100 residents per acre, that
actually, if you start
thinking about what I said about
Natalie's calculation of
more about collisional hours
than dollars, and this is an
awkward slide, but essentially
instead of thinking about 100
people per acre, we think
about 100 collisional
community hours per
acre per year--
100,000.
And that really is actually
what kind of happened to
Natalie, except she's on
about 1/120 of an acre.
And she's getting 100,000
collisions in a year for about
an hour at a time.
So Natalie is a part of what
creates that collisional
neighborhood and those density
points that people connect in.
So to what I said, Triumph of
the City, I think, is probably
one of the best books that
you can read about
how to build a city.
And the reason why it makes
sense to us is because there's
a general trend around the world
where, while we all are
a little bit over, a half to
60%, in cities today, in our
lifetime, more than three
quarters of the planet will
live in cities.
So if we don't figure out how
to make a city a productive
and happy part of our lives,
we're not going to be
successful in our evolution.
We're going to continue to kind
of spiral out of control.
So essentially, when you combine
all these things,
collisions, community,
co-learning, and all the
environmental variables that I
just described, at the end of
the day, the question
is, what will
people say about downtown?
And to us, we believe that the
big bet is that downtown Vegas
will make you smarter.
And that's something that we've
spent the last two years
trying to figure out
how to create.
And that's really all I have to
share with you right now.
Kind of blasted through a lot.
AUDIENCE: I'm just curious more
about the mobility stuff
that you were talking about.
Have you already launched all
those different services?
And how's it going?
And do people like that?
ZACH WARE: So yes or no.
We are about four to six months
away from phase one
data of Project 100, which will
essentially focus first
on very enhanced driving
mobility, so essentially car
sharing with urban vehicle,
and Teslas, and
bikes in the core.
Phase two, a few months after
that, we'll add drivers to
handle when you can't
drive yourself.
And then we'll expand
geographically to include a
residential area around
downtown.
We're very much on the pathway
to doing that.
By the end of mid September,
we'll have a team of 12
focused on it.
And I expect to launch
in about February.
I think most people, we kind
of point to the Henry Ford
problem quite a bit, that
you know you like Uber.
You know you like bikes.
You know you like to drive.
The question is what happens
when you put all
those things together?
And we don't know what human
behavior will be when all
those options are equalized.
I'm sure people love driving
and riding in a Tesla, but
it's more long term, what
will they do with
that technical ability.
So we're very, very focused on
getting the right experiment
in place, so we can
understand.
AUDIENCE: So it seems like you
guys have done a lot to work
around the area in downtown
through your own startup
endeavors, but what efforts have
you taken, or do you have
plans to take more efforts
to work with existing
infrastructure, and communities,
and institutions,
I guess, in Las Vegas?
Places like UNLV, is really
right down the street.
And it seems like you guys
could do a lot to sort of
partner with them, considering
their budget issues in the
last few years and things like
that, to sort of help create
an incubator for things that you
guys don't have to create
yourself, but you're working
with something
that already there?
ZACH WARE: So you Teach for
America is an example of how
we try to take the work we're
doing and let it spread more
equally across the existing
community and neighborhood.
Specifically, to UNLV, we have
a unique challenge there.
UNLV is not a community
school.
It's very much a commuter
And so yeah, it's about four
miles down the street, but no
one really lives on campus.
It's very much a drive
in, drive out.
We had that same idea a couple
of years ago when we first
started, and we sat down with
the president of the
university.
And his solution to helping
technologist for example
understand what they're learning
today could help them
start a company was to create
a joint MBA masters in
computer science program.
And everything they want to
do is about formality.
And we were more like, just get
them to startup weekend.
Let's just get a car and
drive them down there.
And that's step one.
So we're slowly making progress
in that area, but I
think, in Las Vegas, what the
institutional folks in
casinos, hospitality, education,
there's very much
an insular attitude.
And so we're just saying,
OK, we'll just start.
We'll create something, and then
we'll be here, and the
door is wide open.
But we have to demonstrate
that we've got our stuff
together before, I think,
they'll listen to us.
So the jury is still out.
AUDIENCE: Could you talk a
little bit about sort of the
reception from different ethnic
communities and also
class community?
How's that?
How are they looking?
How are they seeing the Downtown
Project and the
participation.
ZACH WARE: Sure.
The neighborhood that we were
centered in, one, was barren.
So that's a challenge.
A challenge in the sense that
there was no one really there.
Downtown is really weird.
It's dirt and empty hotels.
We're surrounded by very
family focused, but not
necessarily wealthy,
neighborhoods.
Just north of us is
a huge Hispanic.
East of us is a kind
of a hodgepodge.
Generally speaking, our approach
is reflected in the
people that are driving the
things that we're investing in
and building.
Our ethos is not to create
something that's closed off
and to create something
that's accessible.
So ultimately, we think that
when it comes to housing, or
restaurants, or food, we have
this opportunity, for example,
with grocery, to get rid
of a food desert.
And to do that, you have to
have approachable pricing.
And it doesn't just have to
support someone like Tony, it
needs to support someone
who is on food stamps.
So our general approach has
been, to a degree-- someone
asked a similar question at a
talk a couple days ago about
getting more female
entrepreneurs.
And we said, we don't
necessarily have a an outward
focus on doing it, but we're
not closed off at all.
We ultimately think that the
melting pot that is our
neighborhood can support that
diversity over time.
So we're not reaching out too
heavily to any group from any
background.
But if you come visit, you can
tell that it's a pretty
diverse pot of people that are
in our neighborhood, from all
kinds of socioeconomic
backgrounds.
And that's what makes
a magical.
And that's the risk that we
have in investing is that
we'll end up shutting
that group out.
So we try really, really hard
to make sure that we, and no
one else, comes and sort of
gentrifies the neighborhood.
That's a really tough
thing to do.
AUDIENCE: So I know cities
like New York and San
Francisco attract a lot
of talented people
from outside areas.
And other thriving cities, I
guess, have, like Austin and
Pittsburgh have research
or tech universities.
So how does Vegas, or your
project consider bringing in
outside talent and
entrepreneurs, and artists?
ZACH WARE: So we host, just a
random stat, we just about 100
people on our crash
pads every week.
And the number one recurring
visitor home is New York.
I think what happened initially
is similar to what
happened to Zappos.
We focus very heavily on the
experience on the ground.
And when a random person comes
and tells another friend, and
tell another friend, it begins
to compound upon itself.
So what we've seen both
organically and with things
like Tech Cocktail Week and
Catalyst Week is this
explosion of interest and word
of mouth sharing that has led
to 37 companies in Vegas Tech
Fund portfolio, probably 25 of
which are from either Seattle,
or San Francisco, or New York.
They weren't companies we
brought into Vegas.
They wanted to come.
And we happened to participate
in the investment kind of as a
secondary thing.
Dozens more, either in tech
or elsewhere that have
independently moved, I think,
because of the entrepreneurial
spirit on the ground.
It's tough to not be infected
by it when you're there.
So I think, globally, by
focusing more on the
experience when you're there,
and they resources that are
there, we feel like if you come
to Vegas, you're probably
going to come back here
and tell five friends.
And that begins to compound
upon itself.
And we'd rather do that than go
out and buy an ad, if that
make sense.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]